alors c'était juillet de bigard les deux
ans par écran interposé puisque vous
étiez en duplex la manufacture est la
plus ancienne entreprise de digoin
fondée en 1875 depuis eh bien vous avez
parcouru du chemin avec les salariés je
vous propose de regarder ce reportage et
puis on en discute après les anciens
objets de digoin céramique et leur
traditionnelle couleur marron d'un côté
la nouvelle collection de la manufacture
de digoin de l'autre plus colorée plus
moderne à l'image de la personnalité de
la nouvelle directrice qu'elle continue
et fait très très bien pour nous parce
que ça ça fait connaître digoin ça fait
connaître notre région est au contraire
pour nous ça va peut-être ramener un peu
plus de vie vernon il ya beaucoup de
plus de produits
il y avait pas tant le choix quand on
avait les assiettes les verts les pleins
mais pas comme la la il ya plus de
choses
c'est plus joli depuis deux ans
l'entreprise de 19 salariés a pris un
nouveau virage sa directrice corinne
jourdain multiplie les contacts et
visites en vue de futurs partenariats
est mise aussi sur la jeunesse et compte
sur les anciens pour transmettre leur
savoir faire
siri est entré dans l'entreprise à 17
ans il moule les grandes pièces à la
main à ses côtés jean charles arrivé il
ya deux mois que j'ai bien écouté bien
faire ce que ce que les anciens nous
dise
ouais il faut apprendre que tous les
joueurs on apprend des nouveaux gestes
pauline était déjà là à l'époque de
l'ancien patron elle apprécie
aujourd'hui de travailler sur de
nouvelles pièces comme ces vinaigrier
bi-matière engrais et émaillent ce mieux
c'est moderne ça peut plaire à un autre
public jeune on re découvre on leur
donne du temps à la fabrication des
choses
ce temps qui est nécessaire en fait dans
la céramique qu'on peut pas supprimer ou
réduire des étapes justement
et puisque les gens apprécient aussi
c'est que derrière si ces pièces c'est
des hommes des femmes qui façonnent à la
main
donc il ya des petites imperfections
mais c'est normal parce que c'est la
main de l'homme et manufactures voilà
c'est ça une grande signification
depuis septembre la nouvelle collection
de la manufacture de digoin est en vente
chez habitat une fierté pour les dix
voynet et une collaboration de prestige
qui en appelle déjà d'autres je
vouvoyais sourire avec émotion notamment
quand les salariés témoigner oui tout à
fait c'est vrai que depuis que j'ai
repris donc deux ans
quand j'ai repris l'entreprise j'ai
embauché dix personnes aujourd'hui nous
sommes 20 et je pense que je pense que
l'essentiel de la réussite aujourd'hui
c'est grâce à eux
entre autres ça veut dire que l'équipe
est soudée et veut vraiment aller de
l'avant tous ensemble exactement toute
façon c'est un défi à relever ensemble
le défi est assez colossal je pense
qu'on a déjà fait un grand bout de
chemin
pendant ces deux années et c'est vrai
que c'est eux c'est leur savoir-faire en
fait aujourd'hui que j'ai envie de de
mettre en avant vous mettant en avant
les richesses de chacun pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que l'entreprise continue
donc son intérêt
tout à fait il ya deux ans que vous avez
repris l'entreprise n'était pas gagné
c'est un défi est-ce que deux ans après
vous pouvez vous dire que ben vous avez
quand même atteint un certain objectif
alors en fait je suis tellement dedans
que j'ai pas forcément le recul c'est
les gens à l'extérieur les témoignages
mais salariés qui me disent quel chemin
parcouru en effet l'objectif c'était
vraiment de faire renaître cette
entreprise historique de digoin et de la
faire renaître à travers son savoir
faire mais surtout à travers ces objets
les objets utilitaires du quotidien
culinaires des contenants alimentaires
des points moutarde mais vu à travers un
prisme différent de par les finitions
les émaux en fait aujourd'hui
là on va dire la mini révolution initiée
il ya deux ans et uniquement dormons de
montrer aux gens des objets que les gens
connaissent qui font partie de notre
quotidien notre patrimoine de nos
racines mais revisité avec des nouvelles
couleurs que vous approprier enfin
exactement et puis c'est surtout d'être
dans la serre découvrir cesser ses
fabuleuses objets et puis surtout le
voilà on soit dans la transmission en
fait ça fait vraiment partie de notre
patrimoine de notre culture donc je
pense que c'est fondamental vous avez de
nouveaux partenaires de gros clients
est ce que ce sont des partenariats
exclusifs ou est-ce que ça vous ouvre
des horizons
alors en fait
aujourd'hui le développement la
manufacture s'est déjà d'aller vers une
clientèle plutôt grand public alors
qu'avant c'était plutôt une clientèle de
professionnels d'aller vers
des grands magasins et des boutiques
beaucoup à l'export et c'est vrai que et
on fabrique également pour certaines
marques j'ai vu sur le reportage à au
market une nouvelle pièce qu'on fabrique
pour une belle maison qui s'appelle
maison balzac
il est basé en australie et qui a été
monté par une française voilà et c'est
vrai que je pense que la dynamique ce
c'est au tour de nos produits et de
notre collection md 1875 mais aussi
autour de deux collaborations et de
partenariats je pense que c'est
c'est très enrichissant c'est ce qu'on a
fait avec my pour les pots de moutarde
parce que culturellement un pot de
moutarde cet engrais et la manufacture a
toujours fabriqué d'épaulé potable pour
tous les motards dié et il y en avait
deux cents à l'époque a dit jean et dans
ses environs
au vu du succès ce que vous pensez
creusez sion ou continuer j'allais vers
à changer de cap au fur et à mesure non
je pense que la feuille de route au
départ c'était de dire on va s'orienter
justement vers une clientèle grand
public beaucoup à l'export vers des
marques prestigieuses aujourd'hui on est
vendu à londres chez conran shop au
japon aux états unis
demain on sera vendu chez designers
guild chez vingtaine d'années seul donc
vraiment des marques prestigieuses à
paris au printemps aux péages les marais
et donc c'est cette feuille de route on
va la garder c'est un cap
aujourd'hui j'ai mis l'accent sur le
culinaire et l'objectif pour 2010 est
ces deux d'ouvrir une nouvelle voie vers
la poterie horticole engrais là on est
en train de travailler avec des futurs
designers donc des élèves de l'école des
arts décoratifs des arts décoratifs de
paris
voilà donc les uns voir choc qui est en
cours et je suis sûr qu'on va vous sur
ça c'est clair
merci beaucoup d'être venu jusqu'à nous
est passé de très belles fêtes